[Musique]
et
joseph dadoun bonjour bonjour merci de
nous présenter votre exposition
personnellement nous sommes à l'espace
richaud dans l'ancien hôpital royal et
vous exposez actuellement depuis depuis
quand depuis le 5 octobre
voilà et l'exposition se termine le 3
décembre le 3 décembre
voilà qu'on se le dise c'est une entrée
libre en plus ce entrée libre
voilà alors moi j'ai envie de faire
connaissance avec vous joseph dadoun
vous avez une actualité très chargée
outre cette exposition il se passe plein
de choses en ce moment pour vous vous
avez été récemment nommé chevalier des
arts et des lettres déjà et d'une il ya
une semaine vous avez reçu le prix
bernard heym voilà est aussi votre
projet votre travail qui s'appelle à
printemps arabe a intégré les
collections de romans plus forte
recherche pour bientôt
à beaubourg de tout ça c'est énorme
prestigieux c'est à une belle
reconnaissance d'un travail et intégrer
les collections ça veut dire quoi
rendement chaque année il ya un comité
qui se réunit à pompidou de critique
d'art de commissaire d'expo et qu'ils
vont faire un choix des oeuvres
importantes à intégrer dans le musée
d'accord donc ça veut dire qu'on appelle
son à beaubourg
on ne les voit pas pour l'instant parce
qu'une exposition c'est un travail
énorme à mettre en place et qu'un jour
vous nous le dire et ça on viendra vous
voir à beaubourg bon ça c'est génial
après vous avez fait vous êtes et plein
de travaux importants bien évidemment
celui qui est actuellement au louverain
le clip est plus d'ailleurs c'était le
film que j'ai réalisé en 2006 oui j'ai
réalisé en l'ouvrant 2006 avec l'actrice
ronit elkabetz qui est décédé il ya un
an la pauvre avec les costumes de
christian lacroix et le film s'appelle
sion et on le voit encore alors le film
et dans la collection du musée du louvre
et
il est
visible sur internet il a été présenté
il ya quelques mois la cinémathèque de
bologne et au louvre dans le cadre d'un
cycle qui s'intitulait le grand louvre
d'accord donc si on health & o n
ici notre exposition d'aujourd'hui ce
sillon est si deux lots n s car il y en
a plusieurs
voilà et racontez-nous alors vous vous
êtes né à nice je crois oui après qu'est
ce qui s'est passé dans votre vie à cinq
ans alors je suis né à nice mon père est
breton mais ça ma mère est née en
algérie
et donc elle avec la guerre elle est
venue en france
et quand j'avais l'âge de 6 ans ma
mairie a décidé d'immigrer en israël
hélas les autorités de l'immigration
nous on
mis dans un camp
deux caravanes avec des immigrés de
d'ethiopie donc on a vécu pendant un an
dans le désert dans des caravanes quel
désert le désert du negev d'accord et
vatry s'était offert slovaquie me voilà
donc on était dans ces caravanes et
ensuite donc on a on a reçu des balles
on a été déplacé dans une maison dans
une unité d'habitation dans cette ville
périphérique ofakim qui est une ville
ouvrière qui dans les années 80 a
péréclité quand toutes les usines de
textiles sont été fermées donc c'est la
chine commençaient déjà à l'époque à
temps les marchés et marché
et c'est une ville aussi mixte 7 et
culturel c'est-à-dire toute cette région
là qui est à la frontière de gaza
donc c'est une ville j'ai grandi dans
une ville qui a été bombardé pendant 15
ans face à kim
voilà donc c'est vraiment cessé de vivre
des deux côtés du côté de fatim du côté
de gaza
c'est un endroit de guerre c'est une zoé
hier et puis vient ce de vieira non
permanente mais malgré toute cette
ambiance très très dur on vivait dans
une future de mixité c'est à dire j'ai
grandi avec les bédouins qui était donc
des palestiniens n'est palestiniens mais
avec une nationalité israélienne
d'accord donc on vivait en contact
puisque les bédouins d'origine
palestinienne vivant en israël il son
directeur de l'hôpital professeur
docteur juge enfin voilà mais il ya
cette mixité culturelle donc j'ai eu
tout de suite en moi cette identité
hybride d'être en même temps français
d'être là il vient d'avoir une culture
judéo arabe judéo chrétienne mon père
est breton ma mère est née en algérie
cette histoire de l'exil
parallèlement excusez moi je coupe vous
continuiez à faire des allers-retours
avec nice voilà
mais vous n'avez pas eu une scolarité
figé à opaque ofakim mais vous étiez
entre les deux
total via un petit peu particulière
d'une vie par très particulier il ya
toujours d'être entre deux mondes
redemande être entre deux mondes et puis
à chaque fois quand alors quand
j'arrivais en i en france on me disait
mais tué israélien
et quand j'étais en israël on me disait
tu es français thierry breton voilà donc
il ya c'est que voilà c'est compliqué
sont de culture extrême voilà voilà
d'accord deux opposés alors dites moi
vous étiez destiné à être à ben oui
d'accord
et malgré cela vous avez vous êtes
tourné très jeune très vite vers le
dessin qui était votre bouée de secours
je croirais pour moi pour moitié à une
bouée de sauvetage
c'était de sortir des carcans de la
religion des religions je dirai tout
court oui parce que voir qu'ils soient
quelle qu'elle soit puisse que jérusalem
est une ville détroit au lit de l'ancien
grande région mais j'ai vu aussi cette
condition de très très difficile de de
la religion en même temps en moi j'ai
cette spiritualité dont j'ai hérité de
ces religions mais c'est une
spiritualité qui est artistique n'est
pas derrière il n'y a pas de barrière on
est d'accord car quand alors à nice vous
avez moins de 20 ans vous faites votre
première exposition dans une galerie
prestigieuse et puis voilà on en est là
ici à versailles un des premiers le
premier artiste contemporain à excuser
d'ailleurs en ce lieu
classique d'ailleurs et nous sommes dans
une des premières oeuvres que vous avez
intitulé que ce que noir voilà alors dit
non plus qu'elle
le kiosque noir c'est un autoportrait
que j'ai donc cette c'est une cabane où
il n'y a aucun clou visible dans cette
cabane car se trouve d'ailleurs à
l'intérieur de cette cabane elle est
tout noir
c'est une boîte et cette boîte elle
évoque trois références et soir à pistes
possibles pour vous élections pour moi
donc d'une part il ya le carré noir le
cube noir de tony smith dans l'histoire
de l'art à minimal de l'histoire de
l'art ensuite il ya le carré noir en
velours de la mecque
donc voilà cet esprit là et puis aussi
cette cabane des hébreux qui se
déplaçaient dans le désert d'un désert à
l'autre donc s est il construisait des
cabanes mais c'est l'idée de sortir de
son confort personnel de nos habitations
aujourd'hui où tout est fermé avec les
caméras de surveillance le béton les
harnésiens de personnel voilà on est
dans un affaire mme marie cadet est
d'être là dans cette histoire de dire je
sors de mon d'une condition stable et je
vais dans l'instable je vais dans
quelque chose au vert dans l'ouverture
alors voilà et dans l'ombre
oui la méditerranée la question de
l'ombre mais c'est la voilà et donc là
on se trouve le projet c'est de vendre
de la nourriture noire ou blanche
je suis en contact avec des chefs d un
centre scientifique de l'institut
weizmann pour concevoir cette nourriture
donc c'était à cette idée mais une fois
la journée terminée de ce contact social
avec le monde je rentre dans une autre
boîte qui est à l'intérieur cette boîte
est blanche et c'est la boîte du sommeil
et cette architecture de cette cabane
aussi j'ai été très imprégné de
l'architecturé égyptienne funéraire est
donc dans cette cabane
les portes se ferment on ne voit pas de
serrure on ne voit pas de poignées alors
nous on est dans un mystère on est très
petite porte aussi qui fait 10 cm sur 10
cm et c'est la porte du serpent n'écarte
être que le serpent dans
dormant dans avec cette cabane dans la
dans le désert peut-être qu'il ya un
serpent qui va rentrer ou pas donc ça
évoque aussi ce serpent la question de
la sexualité la question de la
psychanalyse
parce que l'idée c'était de faire une
architecture autoportrait aujourd'hui on
est dans des architectures standard et
donc la question de notre histoire
personnelle
de la psychanalyse de la culture est
totalement inhibé d'accord donc cette
cabane c'est vous voilà c'est joseph
devenu voilà votre double voilà très
bien et j'ai oublié de dire on a oublié
de dire vous êtes auto didacte ci parce
que quand on vous a fait étudier de
façon être ramin vous de votre côté vous
vous êtes formé à l'art pour quelques
hommes coiffés
juste une petite parenthèse que je
referme voilà donc ça c'est une première
oeuvre
après nous avons une autre qui
représenteront encore plus ce titre sion
je trouve pas ça c'est personnel
tout à fait et comment on peut la
décrire alors alors c'est un sol oui
c'est un sol de goudron réalisé sur de
la moquette
ça c'est une partie de cette oeuvre qui
fait huit mètres sur 4 mètres et l'autre
partie ce sont quatre toiles sur châssis
avec du goudron de la malachite dans la
poudre de marbre de la poudre d'or de la
poudre de faire de la poudre de la
poudre de cuivre
et le tout est mélangé je voulais
travailler avec le goudron pour
plusieurs raisons oui pourquoi le
goudron pour être matière un petit peu
oui le goudron déjà dans le désert on a
ces gisements de goudron or aujourd'hui
le goudron est un le goudron qu'on
utilise est un poison et c'est un
mélange d'agrégats de pétrole ensuite il
y a dans le goudron la matière de
l'ouvrier voilà donc pour moi j'étais
connecté
comme je viens de cette ville ouvrière
où j'ai grandi annoncée dans cette
périphérie mal en haute banlieue
voilà tout à fait tout à fait
ou justement son vécu les bédouins et
tout le monde envie qu'on vivait
ensemble dans cette périphérie
je voulais faire de l'art avec un
élément ouvriers dac donc j'utilise des
spatules
d'ouvriers de maçon et le gel
d'instruments l'aise je voulais
travailler avec ça mais aussi le goudron
permet aussi de nous protéger de l'eau
donc mon père comme il était marin et
qu'il a travaillé toute sa vie aussi
dans des bateaux il ya cette histoire
entre le goudron et low kick off dans
les ports et l'eau on va la retrouver
nos vos dessins oui n'est ce pas parce
que à l'étagé au dessus nous avons
quantité de dessin gigantesque aussi ou
pas il ya plusieurs tailles de papier
imprégné airs imprégné de vagues d'eau
et surtout alors on sort du noir la wii
expliquez moi qui l'ait cela il ya des
fleurs wells et fleurs elles ont une
taille humaine faire fleurir le désert
de fakim c'est un peu votre lettre
motivée je fais un projet social
justement et culturels après la
naissance ouais et la voiture est le
désert culturel well un désert culturel
et ce désert aussi qui reste un désert
puisque tout le monde tourne le dos et
ne comme c'est pas sexy ya rien à voir
donc on va là où il ya des militaires
seront gâtés l'aviez fait voilà tout à
fait au total 40 espadon donc là où les
dessins mais les fleurs la douleur alors
les fleurs pour que l'eau alors pourquoi
parce que les fleurs
d'enjeux dans au vide dans la mythologie
grecque il ya ces garçons et ces filles
qui sont à l'accueil que les dieux leur
font la cour et quand il meurt ces
garçons et ces filles ils deviennent des
fleurs et des arbres c'est la métaphore
de l'humain la métaphore de l'humain
avec des racines elles sont des racines
mais elles ne sont pas enseignées dans
la terre selon racines sont libres donc
elles peuvent se déplacer dans l'espace
donc il ya cette histoire là de ce va et
vient ensuite il ya le texte sur la
fleur où il ya écrit lost in the sea
d'accord et sa loge et loïs et l'eau et
s'est perdue dans la mer donc perdu dans
la mer pourquoi parce qu'aujourd'hui on
a tout ce qui se passe en méditerranée
tous les migrants toute cette
catastrophe
il ya eu aussi
les migrants après la seconde guerre
mondiale et
rohm and haas ça serait bien sûr il ne
faut pas oublier que le radeau de la
méduse s'est trouvée pendant quelques
années à versailles avant d'arriver au
louvre nous irons à lait emb a regardé
le film que vous proposez les trois
films ont terminé notre interview tout a
dit moi tout à fait qu'est-ce qu'on
vende mossala on voit le film sion avec
ronit elkabetz voyons cette femme qui au
qui est l'allégorie de jérusalem qui est
une femme libre
une femme pure une femme un pur une
mariée divorcée life une prostituée elle
est un cas de femmes et elles se
baladent dans les départements de la
mésopotamie
elle se débat dans dans le département
de la peinture et donc il ya toute cette
histoire de la colonisation de du
patrimoine égyptien et pour moi les
musées il ya aussi une dimension de
cimetière historique
voilà merci beaucoup je remercie
[Musique]